-Guys, I'm very excited
about this.
Next Tuesday, I have a new
children's book coming out
[ Cheering and applause ]
called...
This is a goodie.
Yeah.
"More than Paris
and the Eiffel Tower?
More than cats
with SUPER cat powers."
[ Awws, laughter, and applause ]
Anyway, it's -- Yeah.
Don't cry yet, Higgins.
[ Laughter ]
But it is a little bit
of a weeper.
-Yeah.
-Sweet.
-But, to celebrate,
all next week,
we're going to be showcasing
some very talented grandmas
on the show,
[ Awws and applause ]
from all over the country.
Musicians, dancers, comedians,
lots more.
So look for that
every night next week.
It's going to be fun.
Nana Week!
[ Cheering and applause
continues ]
Nana.